die haare werden länger weil ich nicht
mehr zum friseur kann
ja nun starten wir meinen damit er nicht
begrüße sie recht herzlich
heute zum pressebriefing
robert-koch-institut am dritten april
er wird wie üblich ein statement abgeben
und danach beantworten wir ihre fragen
ja guten morgen meine damen und herren
zunächst eine kurze übersicht über die
lage in der welt und dann gehen wir
natürlich wieder er detaillierte auf
deutschland ein
wie erwartet steigen weltweit die zahlen
wir haben inzwischen über 100 millionen
offiziell gemeldete fälle stand zweiter
14 uhr
die vereinigten staaten haben insgesamt
über 216.000 fälle inzwischen gemeldet
in italien über 110.000 fälle und in
spanien sind es mehr als 102.000 fälle
sie finden alle detailinformationen auf
den websites der
weltgesundheitsorganisation und des
europäischen center for disease control
wo er alle diese zahlen eingestellt sind
und wir verlinken von unserer website
auf diese zahlen die sie jederzeit
nachlesen können wie sieht die situation
in deutschland aus heute das ist der
stand dritter vierter 0 uhr zu diesem
zeitpunkt aktualisieren werden wir die
zahl noch unserem dashboard offiziell
gemeldet waren zu dem zeitpunkt und
80.000 kurve fälle
das ist eine differenz zum vortag von
mehr als 6000 das heißt die zahl nehmen
weiter zu die gemeldeten zahlen nähmen
zu darunter waren insgesamt 1000 17
todesfälle
auch hier haben wir mehr zu verzeichnen
und zwar 145 zum vortag
damit beträgt die gesamt inzidenz
insgesamt 96 fälle pro 100.000 einwohner
und die gesamt incidents schwankt
natürlich in verschiedenen teilen
deutschlands nur als beispiel in bayern
liegt sie momentan bei 155 fällen pro
100.000 und in hamburg bei 141 fällen
mecklenburg vorpommern 29 fälle pro
100.000
wir schätzen die zahl der genesenen mit
23.800 die anzahl der neu übermittelten
fälle ist auf einem ähnlichen niveau wie
am vortag und die fallzahlen werden
täglich aktualisiert sie können sie ganz
detailliert auf unserem dashboard
abrufen dass sie über unsere corona
kurve 19 website finden können
doch sehen sie sehr viele details auch
bis auf landkreisebene und zur
altersstruktur der patienten und ich
möchte auch noch mal darauf hinweisen
dass wir jeden tag einen neuen
situationsbericht mit einer
lage-einschätzung erstellen auch den
finden sie auf unserer website dieser
bericht wird immer spätnachmittags
eingestellt was wissen wir über die
kogit 19 fälle in deutschland
die betroffenen personen sind momentan
48 jahre alt im durchschnitt 51 prozent
sind männer 49 prozent frauen und für
rund 58.000 fälle liegen uns klinische
informationen vor die häufigsten
symptome dafür vor husten 53% und fieber
42 prozent von 1.250 fällen wissen wir
dass sie eine lungenentzündung
entwickelt haben und für insgesamt
58.000 fälle liegen informationen zur
hospitalisierung vor das heißt sie sind
ins krankenhaus eingewiesen worden und
bei rund 8000 fällen wurde eine
hospitalisierung übermittelt das heißt
das sind 14 prozent die todesfälle in
deutschland ich sagte dass bislang
gemeldet wurden 1017 personen die im
zusammenhang mit 19 verstorben sind 145
mehr als das gestern der fall war
damit beträgt der anteil der
verstorbenen an den fällen inzwischen
1,2 prozent ich hatte das bereits
angekündigt dass wir davon ausgehen
müssen was die sterberate steigt und das
ist auch der fall
es befinden sich noch viele co wird 19
fälle in stationärer behandlung
und das heißt also wir müssen davon
ausgehen dass mehr menschen sterben und
die sterberate weiter ansteigt bislang
waren die verstorbene person im
durchschnitt 80 jahre alt und unter den
verstorbenen waren 872 70 jahre und
älter
die bislang jüngste verstorbene person
war 28 jahre alt und litt an einer
vorerkrankung wenn wir uns die
altersgruppen anschauen dann sehen wir
dass jünger als 60 jahre insgesamt 55
personen waren unter den verstorbenen
zwischen 60 und 69 jahren insgesamt 89
personen und zwischen 70 und 79 jahren
260 personen das heißt also sie sehen
dass auch menschen die jünger als 60
jahre sind leider an dieser krankheit
versterben können das ist die
lage-einschätzung lassen sie mich nur
noch ein paar punkte machen und zwar
möchte ich beginnen mit dem thema masken
mund nasenschutz das ist ein thema dass
doch viele in der bevölkerung
interessiert und ich möchte noch mal die
position des robert koch instituts
deutlich machen
wir müssen unterscheiden es gibt einen
sogenannten medizinischen mund
nasenschutz das sind auch die
sogenannten op masken und es gibt
sogenannte ffp masken diese masken
müssen für das medizinische personal
vorbehalten bleiben für die bevölkerung
gilt folgendes um sich selbst und andere
vor ansteckung zu schützen bleibt und
wird auch so bleiben das wichtigste
abstand zu halten
eine infektion die über tropfen
tröpfcheninfektion übertragen wird vor
der schützen sich am besten indem man
schon an abstand hält uns von mindestens
anderthalb meter
die gute händehygiene die wir ebenfalls
von beginn an propagieren und die husten
und niesen regeln beachten
das bleibt bestehen das bleibt wichtig
und das sollten sie immer beherrschen
stoffmasken auch behelfs massen oder
textil massen genannt könnten dabei
helfen tröpfchen beim husten oder
sprechen zurückzuhalten
sie könnten dabei helfen andere zu
schützen
aber sie helfen nicht dabei den
maskenträger selbst zu schützen
das ist wirklich sehr wichtig zu
verstehen es gibt für diesen fremdschutz
bislang keine wissenschaftlichen belege
das sage ich deutlich aber es erscheint
plausibel dass man einen fremdschutz
ausüben kann
neuere studien zeigen dass ein teil der
kogit 19 infizierten so leichte symptome
hat dass sie diese symptome kaum
bemerken oder dass sie gar keine
symptome haben und in der regel trotzdem
ausscheiden an orten an denen man den
abstand nicht immer einhalten kann zum
beispiel in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
oder im supermarkt da könnte das tragen
einer maske in solchen fällen vermutlich
das risiko reduzieren andere anzustecken
das ist unsere einschätzung aber ich
möchte das noch mal betonen man selber
wird nicht vor der übertragen geschützt
mit einer solchen maske wer krank ist
und symptome hat der sollte unbedingt zu
hause bleiben und bei bedarf ärztliche
hilfe in anspruch nehmen wenn sie krank
sind
bitte gehen sie dann nicht einkaufen
bitte fahren sie nicht u bahn auch nicht
mit einer textil maske sondern wenn sie
krank sind bleiben sie bitte zu hause
und für alle anderen gilt damit diese
stoff textil oder behelfs masken oder
wie immer wie sie nennen funktionieren
ist ganz wichtig dass diese maske
richtig sitzt also eng anliegt sie
mussten nach durchfeuchtung gewechselt
werden
und wichtig ist beim tragen der maske
dürfen sie sich nicht ständig anfassen
oder zurecht zupfen
denn dann fassen sie sich ins gesicht
und genau das soll man nicht das heißt
also diese masken dürfen keinen falschen
schutz vor täuschen sondern sie müssen
sie gut behandeln und gut damit umgehen
denn das schlimmste was passieren könnte
wenn das tragen der maske dazu führt
dass man sich in einer falschen
sicherheit wiegt man muss auch mit einer
solchen textil maske oder behelf maske
stoffmaske wie immer wie sie nennen
abstand halten sich an die husten und
niesen regeln halten und die
händehygiene beachten sonst schadet das
tragen einer solchen maske mehr als dass
es nützt das ist die einschätzung die
wir im moment dazu geben
auch wir müssen die situation immer
wieder neu bewerten die lage ist ja
immer dynamisch und generell so dass wir
optionen immer wieder prüfen und
anpassen werden so wie wir das seit
beginn dieser epidemie tun eine tägliche
lage-einschätzung das ist unser job
ein wort noch zu öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln
es ist sehr wichtig dass die menschen
auch in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
abstand halten können dass es dort keine
menschenansammlungen gibt das kann eine
übertragung von saas kopf zwei
begünstigen
deshalb sollte dort wo es nötig ist die
taktung der öffentlichen verkehrsmittel
erhöht werden oder sollten den zügen und
s bahn mehr waggons eingesetzt werden
ein aspekt den ich auch noch ansprechen
möchte heute es geht um die trennung von
patienten strömen krankenhäusern das ist
mir eine hinweis für die
krankenversorgung wir sehen wie
befürchtet auch immer mehr kurven 19
ausbrüche in krankenhäusern und
altenheimen mit teilweise schlimmen
folgen es gibt doch todesfälle unter den
betroffenen und es gibt zahlreiche
erkrankungen auch beim medizinischen
personal das dann natürlich für die
versorgung ausfällt daher möchte ich
noch einmal ganz ausdrücklich darauf
hinweisen wie wichtig es ist dass kurt
19 patienten und verdachtsfälle von
anderen patienten räumlich getrennt
werden um weitere infektionen zu
verhindern
das gilt für krankenhäuser das gilt aber
natürlich auch für arztpraxen das rkw
hat deshalb auf seiner internetseite
verschiedene empfehlungen veröffentlicht
wie man patientenströme optimal trennen
kann
nochmal mein appell hier an alle
einrichten in der krankenversorgung
bitte schauen sie sich diese empfehlung
an und handeln sie entsprechend man
damen und herren es bleibt die strategie
des robert-koch-instituts wie wir sie
seit vielen wochen propagieren sie ruht
auf drei säulen
unser ziel bleibt es die verbreitung von
kogit 19 zu verlangsamen damit wir das
gesundheitssystem möglichst nicht
überfordern und alle patienten
bestmöglich versorgt werden können das
ziel erreichen wir durch die drei säulen
erstens eindämmung erkrankte frühzeitig
erkennen isolieren kontakte
nachverfolgen quarantäne isolierung das
sind die klassischen aufgaben des
öffentlichen gesundheitssystems der
lokalen gesundheitsbehörden darum müssen
wir die maximal unterstützen
zweitens das schützen besonders
gefährdete gruppen und drittens die
erhöhung der kapazitäten in der
ärztlichen versorgung hier geht es um
krankenhausbetten und intensivbetten und
beatmungsgeräte von test kapazitäten in
laboren
ich möchte noch mal ganz deutlich sagen
dass wir alle dazu beitragen können dass
diese verlangsamung gelingt und zwar
dadurch dass wir abstand halten
zu hause bleiben wenn es geht und wenn
wir krank sind sowieso
es gibt im moment sehr klare regeln der
bundesregierung die ihnen und uns allen
einiges abverlangen das ist mir bewusst
aber es ist leider so wir stehen am
anfang dieser epidemie
und wir dürfen jetzt mit diesen regeln
nicht nachlassen um die zahl der
neuinfektionen maximal reduzieren zu
können
wir sehen weiterhin dass es gelingt
lokale ausbrüche einzudämmen
dafür sind für den lokalen
gesundheitsbehörden sehr dankbar und sie
brauchen dafür unsere unterstützung und
mitarbeit
danke sehr vielen dank
dann kommen jetzt zu den fragen noch
eine kurze vorbemerkung es leider nicht
möglich alle fragen wiederzugeben sind
einfach zu viele wird bitten um
verständnis
am kriterien für die auswahl waren das
ein thema noch nicht statement
beantwortet wurde
dass die fragen nicht schon in einem
früheren briefing beantwortet wurden
die reichweite des mediums natürlich und
wir haben uns bemüht die fragen auch
wirklich auf eine frage pro medium zu
begrenzen
dann legen wir los die süddeutsche
zeitung fragt wie das sie sagten dass
neben der zahl der korona fälle in
deutschland auch andere kriterien die
krankenhaus kapazitäten eine rolle bei
der frage spielen wann und wie die
einschränkung des öffentlichen lebens
wieder gelockert werden können würden
sie bitte erneut in welche faktoren sie
hier einbeziehen also zum einen ist es
die reproduktionsrate also das heißt die
zahl wie viele personen von einer
infizierten person angesteckt werden
wenn denn diese zahl null
und wenn diese zahl unter 1 gedrückt
wird dann lässt die epidemie langsam
nach das ist unser ziel
wir haben die zahl schon auf 1 gedrückt
durch die maßnahmen das wissen wir und
wir hoffen dass wir sie weiter und das
zweite ist die inzidenz das heißt also
die häufigkeit einer krankheit unter
100.000 personen da gibt es bestimmt
gemäss zahlen
das andere ist auch insgesamt natürlich
die anzahl der erkrankten im vergleich
zu der kapazität des gesundheits
gebietes in dem entsprechenden gebiet
über das wir reden das heißt also es
gibt auch regionale unterschiede da
natürlich und das nächste ist einfach
auch wie dynamisch die situation
überhaupt in einem bestimmten gebiet ist
also das heißt wie viel neuinfektionen
pro zeiteinheit kommen dazu das sind die
wesentlichen merkmale als ist immer eine
balance zwischen den reinen
epidemiologischen zahlen auch natürlich
unter berücksichtigung einer möglichen
dunkelziffer und der kapazität die im
gesundheitssystem zur verfügung steht
die frage war auch noch mal eine
nachfrage wo befinden sich diese beiden
werte in deutschland zurzeit also wir
sehen dass wir zurzeit bei 1 sind etwa
und das seit einigen tagen dass das
scheint sich zu stabilisieren aber wie
gesagt wir müssen unter 1 kommen darum
hoffen wir dass das in den nächsten
tagen auch gelingt ich wüsste gerne ob
es szenarien gibt mir ein wieder anfang
nachdem
nach den einschränkungen aussehen kann
fängt das normale leben dann
schrittweise wieder an erst firmen dann
schulen restaurants also an diesen
überlegungen wird natürlich gearbeitet
ich es gibt noch keine finalen pläne das
ist eine sehr sehr schwierige aufgabe
das durchzuführen und es werden
verschiedenste szenarien sicher
durchdacht ich persönlich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass alles gleichzeitig
wieder eröffnet wird ich gehe von einer
seriellen staat aus heute fragt wie
lautet ihr fazit nach fast zwei wochen
der erweiterten kontakt sperren
na ja also wir sehen dass sich die
zahlen die die geschwindigkeit der
ausbreitung reduziert das sagte ich eben
wir hatten teilweise je nachdem welche
zeiträume wir betrachten er 0 werte von
fünf teilweise sogar von 7 also deutlich
höheren sehr sehr starke dynamik wir
sehen dass es wirkt wir sehen aber nicht
nur dass es das anhand der zahlen also
an der dynamik der zahlen der
abflachenden und der reproduktionsrate
sondern wir sehen es auch im mobilitäts
profilen wir haben ja freundlicherweise
daten zur verfügung gestellt bekommen
die uns zeigen dass insgesamt die
mobilität in der bevölkerung schon stark
lasten nachlässt und da sieht man sehr
schön auch anhand der der daten in denen
die bundesregierung bestimmte maßnahmen
angeordnet hat oder empfohlen hat und
man sieht dann regional auch große
unterschiede
manche städte zum beispiel hat die
mobilität um mehr als 50 prozent
nachgelassen anderen nur um 40 prozent
das hilft aber ich möchte noch mal ganz
klar sagen das muss auch weiter
eingehalten werden abstand halten ist
das entscheidende gebot und zu hause
bleiben sonst kriegen wir diese r 0
nicht unter 1 also das muss auch weiter
aufrechterhalten werden rtl n-tv fragt
inwieweit hat sich die oder inwiefern
hat sich die strategien deutschland seit
ausbruch der pandemie geändert die hat
sich nicht geändert wir hatten immer die
gleiche strategie die strategie war
immer verlangsamung verlangsamung der
ausbreitung mit dem ziel die kapazitäten
im gesundheitssystem zu erhöhen das ist
auch gelungen
wir haben schon deutlich mehr
intensivbetten in deutschland und wir
haben auch die zahl der
beratungsplätze schon deutlich erhöht
und die zahl der test kapazitäten ist
auch erhöht worden
wir hatten im letzten woche wenn ich das
richtig erinnere fast 350 360.000
testungen von denen so rund 78 prozent
positiv waren das ist auch eine große
steigung das heißt also das zeigt
erfolge und das läuft bislang sehr sehr
gut ob das ausreicht ob das
gesundheitssystem nicht über stresst
wird das werden wir sehen
wir können das nicht sicher sagen aber
wir tun alles um so viel wie möglich
menschenleben zu retten und die
strategie trägt sie ist unverändert
richtig
die berliner morgenpost fragt noch vor
fünf wochen schätze das lka das risiko
für die bevölkerung durch ko mit 19 als
gering bis mäßig ein vor gut zwei wochen
noch als mäßig wie bewerten sie das
die entwicklung der pandemie bewerten
sie heute vor dem hintergrund der
entwicklung der pandemie diese aussagen
und die kommunikative wirkung in politik
und öffentlichkeit hätte das rk ii
früher deutlicher warnen müssen
wir können ja immer nur die warnung
ausgeben die momentan fakt ist das heißt
also die warnung hin von 282
gegebenheiten ab erstens wie ist die
situation im ausland also wir haben
immer unterschieden bei der
risikobewertung wie groß ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass das virus nach
deutschland kommt das ist ein teil der
risikowahrnehmung und wenn es dann das
virus in deutschland ist wie groß ist
dann die wahrscheinlichkeit dass große
teile der bevölkerung infiziert werden
das sind zwei komponenten der
risikobewertung und wenn wir schauen
dann hatten wir ja im januar lediglich
16 fälle und dann hatten wir einige
wochen überhaupt keine fälle das heißt
das virus war nach dem damaligen
aktuellen kenntnisstand eben nicht in
deutschland und in so einem fall ist
natürlich die gefahr für die bevölkerung
auch gering
die risikoeinschätzung ist aktuell und
erfolgt anhand aller daten die uns zur
verfügung stehen
dpa fragt es gibt meldungen dass 2300
medizinische mitarbeiter in kliniken mit
corona infiziert sind ist durch die
steigenden infektionszahlen bei ärzten
und pflegern das gesundheitssystem
gefährdet sollte infiziertes personal
weiter arbeiten
also das ist ein ganz wichtiger aspekt
darum müssen sich medizinisches personal
also sowohl ärztinnen und ärzte als auch
das fachpersonal übrigens auch
pflegepersonal natürlich schützen vor
infektion
dafür benötigt man schutzkleidung und
wir wissen ja die wahrheit ist dass
momentan nicht überall ausreichend
schutzkleidung haben die menschen müssen
sie schützen damit sie weiter arbeiten
können wenn medizinisches fachpersonal
infiziert ist dann darf es
selbstverständlich nicht weiterarbeiten
dort wird teilweise je nach krankenhaus
unterschiedliche testmethoden etabliert
manche werden frei getestet das heißt
also nach einem bestimmten zeitraum
werden in regelmäßigen zeitraum pcr test
durchgeführt um zu sehen ob das personal
noch viren ausscheidet oder nicht also
wieder in öl noch infektiös ist oder
nicht
prinzipiell kann natürlich ein personal
das infiziert ist nicht am patienten
aber die sterberate durch das virus ist
in deutschland diese woche deutlich
gestiegen ist auch hier zu erwarten dass
man sterberate wie in china mit 4
prozent sehen wird fragt bloomberg news
also die sterberate wird steigen davon
gehen wir aus das ist unsere
einschätzung wie hoch sie steigt das
vermag ich nicht zu sagen
der bayerische rundfunk br 24 fragt was
entgegnen sie den vorwurf dass die
zählweise der korona todesfälle dazu
führt dass zu viele todesfälle gezählt
werden weil gestorben mit und nicht
gestorben an gezählt wird warum geht es
nicht anders
also ich würde dem entgegnen dass wir
eigentlich davon ausgehen dass die
todesfälle sogar unterschätzt werden
es werden wahrscheinlich sogar mehr
menschen an bord sterben als als
gemeldet werden es gibt eine neuere
publikationen dazu auf vom imperial
college der erst vor drei tagen häufig
publiziert wurde das liegt einfach daran
dass man nicht bei jedem menschen ist
schafft ihn zu testen und das man man
hat auch oft
den fall dass wenn zum beispiel eine
obduktion durchgeführt wird wenn eine
person im rahmen von kurve 19 gestorben
ist dass man im obduktion smart rial
später das virus gar nicht mehr
nachweisen kann
aber die person ist eben im rahmen
dieser infektion gestorben also ich gehe
davon aus dass wir mehr tote haben als
offiziell gemeldet werden die id
tagesthemen fragen oder kommentieren
zahlreiche wissenschaftler fordern die
erhebung einer repräsentativen
stichprobe unter anderem zur ermittlung
gesicherter daten zur ausbreitung unfall
sterblichkeit von corona hält dass er
keine solche repräsentative stichprobe
ebenfalls für sinnvoll
und so lange soll ich durchgeführt
werden wir denken dass das nicht sehr
zielführend ist also zum einen haben wir
sehr hohe testergebnis also wir testen
sehr viele menschen ja jeden monat das
ist nicht repräsentativ aber das gibt
uns natürlich einen einblick zu anderen
führen wir serologische studien durch
unter anderem mit blutspendediensten
aber auch in in zum beispiel ausbruchs
gebieten in zukunft und wir denken dass
wir durch diese testungen also gezielte
testungen unter bestimmten
epidemiologischen zusammenhängen dass
wir dort sogar aussagefähigere
informationen bekommen
das ist der status und das ist die
aktuelle einschätzung des
robert-koch-instituts das zdf
landesstudio berlin fragt in deutschland
gibt es erste zertifizierte
testmöglichkeiten auf antikörper gegen
das neuartige coronaviren erste labor
die diese jetzt auch für einzelpersonen
anbieten wie bewerten sie das ist das
sinnvoll für den einzelnen ist das
sinnvoll für die gesellschaft ja
serologische tests sind wichtige die
sind sehr wichtig ich habe momentan nur
im kopf zwei tests die wohl gute
qualitätsparameter haben das wird aber
immer noch getestet das ist nicht alles
sehr sehr evidenzbasiert und die sind
wichtig für verschiedene aspekte erstens
mal ist es wichtig für uns zu erfahren
wie viele menschen eben infiziert waren
und gesundet sind und dann auch
hoffentlich die immun sind wir wissen ja
leider immer noch nicht genau wie die
immunität aussieht dass wenn wir auch es
in einigen wochen wissen
und das zweite ist natürlich kann man
bestimmte person wenn sie denn einen
antikörper titer haben kann man sich zum
beispiel überlegen dass sie vielleicht
für bestimmte arbeiten wieder eingesetzt
werden oder er eingesetzt werden als als
andere person das hängt immer vom von
der umgebung ab und von der
fragestellung auf jeden fall sind diese
tests extrem wichtig weil wir nur mit
serologischen tests auf dauer wirklich
die verbreitung der krankheit in der
völker bevölkerung überprüfen können zdf
morgenmagazin und mittagsmagazin fragen
verschiedene mathematiker statistiker
machen darauf aufmerksam dass die
alleinige zählung von positiv getesteten
nur beschränkte aussagefähigkeit hat
weil die selektive auswahl ihre
veränderung und auch die erhöhung der
test zahlen deutlichere auswirkungen auf
die zahl der positiv getesteten hat
warum zählt das rkw nicht die summe der
tests ist die negative ergebnisse für
außer ergebnisse warum wir das nicht tun
ist einfach nicht so einfach für uns
diese zahlen zu erheben wir machen ja
abfragen wir bekommen immer mehr ist und
ich sagte eben dass wir im letzten woche
rund 350.000 nach unserem kenntnisstand
rund 350.000 test durchgeführt wurden
die positiven rate von ungefähr 8
prozent dann ist klar dass im 92 prozent
negativ waren das heißt also diese daten
erheben wir wir versuchen sie so gut wie
weg zu erheben und wir bauen sie in
unsere überlegung auch dann mit ein
die berliner zeitung fragt müssten nicht
gezielter und in einigen gruppen
flächendeckend getestet werden etwa
klinikpersonal beschäftigt in alten und
pflegeheimen
ja das wird in manchen je nach je nach
situation wird das getan oder nochmal
die die wesentliche teil der testung
sind zwei aspekte dass eine
festzustellen ob eine person eben
erkrankt ist und zwar an kuwait 19
erkrankt ist also eine klare
differentialdiagnose also eine ärztliche
handlungen intervention um die personen
behandeln zu können
und der zweite aspekt ist eben im raum
von kontakt nachverfolgung also wenn man
ausbrüche detektiert hat und dann die
kontaktpersonen ob sie nun erster oder
zweiter kategorie sind entsprechend in
quarantäne zu packen oder eben nicht in
quarantäne zu tun
das sind die zwei hauptgebiete für tests
aber es gibt auch einzelne situationen
wo man aus bestimmten gründen vielleicht
gerade mehr wissen möchte das muss dann
immer mit dem lokalen gesundheitsamt
abgesprochen werden da gibt es auch in
die kann
zu unklar die welt fragt nun wurde die
empfehlung zu masken tragen geändert
warum wenn es keinen wissenschaftlichen
beleg gibt der belegt dass die dass das
tragen von community masken tatsächlich
hilft würde die empfehlung des lka
anders ausfallen wenn genügend mund
nasen schutz und atemschutzmasken in
deutschland vorhanden wäre
also wir haben keine empfehlungen zu
masken tragen geändert es gibt eine
änderung die wir in der letzten woche
auf unserer website eingestellt haben
wir haben nach zusammenarbeit mit dem bv
dem bundesinstitut für arzneimittel und
medizinprodukte und auch dem
bundesministerium für arbeit und
soziales dort ist ja der arbeitsschutz
angesiedelt haben wir oder haben haben
haben diejenigen getestet dass man fsp
zwei masken und auch den medizinischen
mund nasenschutz teilweise wieder
verwenden kann wenn man ihn erhitzt über
eine bestimmte zeit 30 minuten 65 bis 70
grad das ist aber keine empfehlungs
änderung im bezug auf das tragen von
masken sondern man kann damit eben was
mehrfach verwenden
die frage hatte sich auch auf die
bevölkerung bezogen hatten wir aber auch
keine empfehlung wenn ich also etwa wenn
die wirte die bild das muss ich leider
sagen wir haben keine empfehlung
geändert dpa audio fragt die empfohlenen
schutzmaßnahmen werden vielerorts
peinlich auf alle genau eingehalten
das gift in berliner u bahn nicht
gestern in der abendlichen rush-hour
waren pro waggon jeweils mehr als 30
personen unterwegs einheiten des
mindestabstands unmöglich ist das nicht
das falsche signal
ja darauf hatte ich eben hingewiesen
also wo immer möglich sollte die taktung
von fahrten der öffentlichen er erhöht
werden und wo immer möglich sollten
immer eher mehr als weniger waggons
eingesetzt werden es ist genauso es muss
jeder muss darauf achten dass er das
abstandsgebot hält aber ich bin ja
selber fahrer von öffentlichen mir fällt
immer wieder auf dass leute halt immer
wieder nur vorne oder hinten einsteigen
und man muss sich natürlich auch
gleichmäßig verteilen auf die waggons
also auch hier ist das verhalten der
menschen schon schlüssel
wir können immer noch auch selber
einiges dafür tun um den abstand zu
halten
die tagesschau fragt der epidemiologe
stefan willich sagt dass corona virus
dafür einen großen teil der bevölkerung
ungefährlich als begründung führte die
italienischen opfer an das
durchschnittsalter habe bei 80 jahren
gelegen die hälfte von ihnen habe
treiber mehr chronische vorerkrankungen
die toten seien damit sehr speziell und
sehr kranker opfer gewesen teilen sie
diese einschätzung
na ja wir wissen ja schon von anfang an
dass das risiko mit zunehmendem alter
mit zunehmender zahl von
grunderkrankungen steigt schwer zu
erkranken
und auch dass das risiko steigt zu
versterben
das ist so dass das ist das einzige was
ich mir sehr lange wissen
aber es gibt eben auch fälle wo junge
gesunde menschen versterben aber das
risiko zu versterben ist für diese
menschen geringer es kommt hier oft in
aspekt an dass dieses virus neu ist wir
keine immunität haben wir keine neben
stoff haben und dadurch einfach der
anteil der bevölkerung der infiziert
wird einfach sehr sehr groß sein wird
und ohne impfstoff werden wir die
epidemie erst beendet haben wir 60 bis
70 prozent der menschen infiziert sind
oder sind viele millionen menschen
und darunter sind eben dann auch viele
gesunde menschen die aber schwer
erkranken können dpa fragt noch sind
laut sind laut levy das ist die
entsprechende für wissenschaftliche
fachgesellschaft rund 8600
intensivbetten frei will bewerten sie
das werden auch die in kürze belegt sein
oder ist die reserve ausreichend also
zunächst mal bin ich sehr froh dass die
bauordnungsbehörde wurden und die
intensiv kapazitäten erhöht wurden
nochmal meine einschätzung nach wie vor
kann ich nicht sicher sein dass die
kapazitäten reichen ich persönlich habe
die einschätzung dass sie nicht reichen
werden
und ich freue mich wenn ich mich täusche
aber je mehr beratungsplätze wir haben
je mehr intensivbetten wir haben desto
mehr menschen leben werden wir retten
können und darum fordere ich weiterhin
auf dass wir die kapazitäten so gut wie
möglich dass der rbb fernsehen fragt
welche rolle können aus sicht des rk ii
die corvette 19 genießen die ja
wahrscheinlich immun sind in der
gesellschaft spielen gibt es
empfehlungen von ihrer seite wird für
die möglichkeit zu freiwilligen 1
zusammen stellen das ist ein guter
gedanke wir machen uns über solche
kontrakte gedanken haben sich aber noch
nicht ausgearbeitet wir wissen ja noch
nicht genau wie hoch die immunität ist
und wie gut die immunität ist aber die
der gedanke es prinzipiell gut ja das
zdf heute journal fragt das lka hat
gemeinsam mit dem fraunhofer institut
für nachrichtentechnik
heinrich-hertz-institut eine plattform
entwickelt auf deren grundlage nun eine
handy app entwickelt werden könnte zur
nachverfolgung von kontakten von kogit
19 infizierten auf welcher basis soll
das funktionieren
ja also ich bin sehr froh über diese
initiative die viele viele
wissenschaftler im hintergrund auch
wirklich mit hohem engagement und und
mit wenig finanzieller unterstützung in
den letzten wochen gemacht haben
das system ist folgendes es geht nicht
darum dass man ortszeit feststellungen
machen kann und auf einzelne personen
zurück schließen kann sondern es geht
darum dass man einen app herunterlädt
freiwillig herunterlädt und dass diese
app dann ermöglicht über eine bluetooth
applikation also über bestimmte strahlen
und wellen zu merken ob ein anderes
handy über eine längere zeit in der nähe
seines eigenen handys gewesen ist
voraussetzung ist natürlich dass diese
handys beide daran diese applikation
heruntergeladen haben und das ermöglicht
den gesundheitsämtern später natürlich
ein viel viel schneller erkennen von
möglichen kontaktpersonen
das ist alles daten geschützt das ist
entsprechend verschlüsselt und es wird
dann aktiviert wenn eine person jetzt
positiv getestet wurde die eine solche
app runtergeladen hat dann kann man auf
dieser oft de mobil auf dem handy der
jeweiligen person sehen ob andere person
15 minuten in einem abstand von zwei
metern etwa in der nähe gewesen waren in
den letzten zwei wochen zum beispiel das
ist ja die inkubationszeit
und dann kann man die direkt informieren
das spart dem gesundheitsamt sehr sehr
viel kraft und zeit und macht eine viel
gezieltere kontakt nach verfolgung
möglich und noch mal
wir werden ja noch wochen und monate
lang diese krankheit in unserem land
solange wir keinen impfstoff haben
werden wir die krankheit haben und so
lange wird eine große last auf den
gesundheitsämtern ruhen die
gesundheitsämter müssen immer wieder
ausbrüche erkennen und niederschlagen
und dafür ist jede hilfe wichtig und wir
brauchen menschen sie brauchen digitale
tools und sie brauchen natürlich auch
dann testsysteme um zu testen ob vor dem
kontakt nachverfolgung positiv sind oder
negativ sind und dass alles was diese
arbeit beschleunigt das alles rettet in
deutschland menschen leben und das ist
eins von vielen werkzeugen und wir bauen
immer mehr werkzeuge auf um die
gesundheitsämter zu unterstützen dann
vielen dank wir sind am ende angekommen
und bis zum nächsten mal danke ihnen
auch